imagine traveling in a foreign country
when you learn the news of your father's
death
now imagine that that death means you
are now at the helm of the British
Empire this is how queen elizabeth ii
discovered that she would no longer be a
princess but instead would be the queen
of the most powerful empire in history
she was only 25 years old and would soon
become the head of one of the world's
most powerful monarchies a post she
would hold for much of the 20th century
Elizabeth wasn't even supposed to be
Queen but as the old saying goes when
humans plan God laughs
Elizabeth was born on April the 21st
1926 do the Duke and Duchess of York a
father Prince Albert was a bad time the
second in line to the monarchy following
the current King George the fifth and
his older brother Edward Prince of Wales
and should her parents or Prince Albert
have had a son the male heirs would jump
ahead of Elizabeth in the line of
succession it was Elizabeth's uncle
Edwards the Prince of Wales whose
behavior altered to this line of
succession in love with an American
divorcee Edward abdicated the throne in
1936 amid a public uproar about his love
life Elizabeth's father became King
George the sixth and Elizabeth became
the next in line to the throne at the
age of just ten reportedly Elizabeth's
younger sister Margaret told her poor
you upon learning the news of the new
line of succession now before the family
was thrust into the role of monarchs
Elizabeth Margaret and their parents
lived a relatively quiet life split
between homes in London and the
countryside Elizabeth was educated at
home by a governess she wasn't around
children her own age with the exception
of her sister which was a somewhat
lonely experience that she tried to
avoid for her own children during these
lessons Elizabeth enjoyed learning about
history and also showed herself to be a
responsible and organized child she even
insisted on properly setting up her toy
horses before bed each night making sure
that each was unsaddled and fed
as intelligent and responsible as she
showed herself to be Elizabeth still
showed herself to be like many other
children in one regard and that was that
she had trouble pronouncing her own name
instead of Elizabeth she said lili-beth
now as a result of the nickname stuck
and it was what her close family would
come to know her as as Elizabeth grew
older and became next in line to the
throne more emphasis was placed on
formal education as a twelve-year-old
she was taught constitutional history
from a member of Eaton's faculty and as
the Archbishop of Canterbury it was her
religious instructor it wasn't exactly
what you'd call a typical education but
it wasn't all dry scholastic studies
being the daughter of the King certainly
did have its perks
do you help Elizabeth social reach and
outdoors education a buckingham palace
chapter of the Girl Guides was started
each Wednesday afternoon 20 fortunate
girls were welcomed to the palace to
take part in outdoors orientated
activities and be part of the future
Queen's social circle
but alas the comfortable innocent
childhood of Elizabeth it was not the
last coming-of-age in the 1930s her life
would be affected by World War two
before she turned 15 by 1939 England was
war and though pressure mounted to send
Elizabeth and Margaret to Canada their
mother would hear of no such thing
instead they were sent to live at
Windsor Castle in 1940 this mid served
two purposes
keeping Elizabeth and Margaret safer
than they might otherwise be in London
but also helping to show the strength of
the country in a time of terrible
upheaval and fear if England was safe
enough for the princesses then it was
safe enough for the rest of the country
- and Brits should be proud and
patriotic to do their duty for the war
just like the young princesses were
doing
now while the royal sisters were staying
in a castle vans were closely watched
over that does not mean the princesses
were completely exempt from all the
fears and uncertainty that comes with
war while they were staying at Windsor
Castle hundreds of bombs were dropped in
the area and like so many of their
countrymen Elizabeth and Margaret were
roused from bed in the middle of the
night rushed to the bomb shelters and
kept on constant alert for the air-raid
siren in October of 1940 at the age of
14 Elizabeth gave a radio address that
was heard throughout England and North
America she discussed the situation that
she and Margaret were in talking about
how they understood what their evacuated
peers were feeling they talked about
being separated from their loved ones
and living in a world turned upside down
by violence but Elizabeth she wanted to
do more for her country than just speak
on the radio she was not yet 18 though
and it wasn't until near the end of the
war that she was given the opportunity
to serve as a trainee ambulance driver
she learned about car repair and photos
of her working became iconic images of
the British war effort on VE Day she
wore her uniform and stood on the
balcony with Prime Minister Churchill
and her parents Elizabeth she was not
yet Queen first even as a teenager she
had shown herself to be quite the leader
so the war ended in 1945 but it's
aftermath remains even for royalty when
Elizabeth married two years after the
end of the war she purchased the fabric
for her wedding gown
using ration coupons but that didn't
mean our dress was a dreary affair it
was made of silk and decorated with over
10,000 pearls agreeing well that was
Prince Philip of Greece a man who'd been
in and out of Elizabeth's life since she
was 13 years old as second cousins they
saw each other at family functions
throughout their lives
teenage Elizabeth she'd been intrigued
by Philip since meeting him in her early
teens but it was when Elizabeth was 17
and he was 22 that the Prince began to
consider marrying her now as we did
mentioned they were second cousins but
such a marriage between cousins is
hardly unusual for royalty for the boys
born in Greece and was a member of the
line of succession to the Greek throne
however he gave up his position in the
line of succession to become a
naturalized British citizen the night
before their wedding he was made the
Duke of Edinburgh Verdoux they announced
their engagement in July of 1947
celebrating the happy occasion with a
garden party in photos from the party
elizabeth is unabashedly excited while
Prince Philip gazes down at her
adoringly only four months later in
November of 1947 the two were married in
a ceremony at Westminster Abbey the
Archbishop's of Canterbury and York
performs the right with royalty around
the world in attendance 200 million
commoners were able to listen invite BBC
radio broadcast after the ceremony
Elizabeth and Philip wife Elizabeth
still wearing her wedding gown waved to
cheering crowds from the balcony of
buckingham palace
shortly after Elizabeth gave birth to
their first child Prince Charles in 1948
a daughter ban was saturd to the family
in 1950 it would be over a decade before
Elizabeth gave birth to her youngest
son's Prince Edward and Prince Andrew as
an interesting aside here Elizabeth was
serving as Queen when Prince Edward and
Prince Andrew were born which makes her
the first Queen in England's history to
give birth while holding the title
it was her husband Philip who had the
difficult duty of passing the word to
his wife that her father had passed the
two knew he was ill in fact they were
traveling in Kenya because the king was
not well enough to travel
internationally so his daughter and
son-in-law took on the duty the trip was
supposed to include travel to Australia
and New Zealand
but of course news of the Kings death
took priority over all else
Elizabeth true to the stoic stereotype
of the British and especially the Royals
reportedly did not succumb to her
emotions upon hearing the news but
instead began planning the practical
steps for what must come next she and
Philip well they returned to England and
it was on that plane flight home that
she finally allowed herself to cry
although of course she never did this in
public even on their flight she hid in
the bathroom and emerged with reddened
eyes but a composed face years later
Elizabeth recalled the implications of
taking the throne at such a young age in
a way I didn't have an apprenticeship
my father died much too young it's a
question of maturing into something that
one's gotten used to and accepting the
fact that here you are and it's your
fate because I think that continuity is
very important it is job for life
preparations for Elizabeth's coronation
ceremony took over a year her father
died in February of 1952 but the
official coronation didn't occur until
June of 1953 it did rain on the day of
her coronation but this did nothing to
temper the excitement of the day for the
British people who had watched this
young woman grow up Elizabeth was
coronated in Westminster Abbey bringing
her into the line of kings and queens
who had been crowned there for nearly a
millennium not even 30 years old
Elizabeth solemnly delivered the
coronation oath which was heard by
millions around the world the ceremony
in a sign of the changing times was the
first British coronation ceremony to be
televised in her coronation speech
Elizabeth looked to the future saying
the following I am sure that this my
coronation is not the symbol of a power
and a splendor that are gone but a
declaration of our hopes for the future
and for the years I may by God's grace
and mess
to be given to rain and serve you as
your queen following the actual ceremony
Elizabeth and dozens of other
dignitaries rode through the streets of
London shared by adoring crowds still
more applauding Brits stood and cheered
her as she waved to them from the
balcony of buckingham palace later in
the evening Elizabeth and Philip moved
into Buckingham Palace after the
coronation but they did not spend much
time there initially instead they took
off on a world tour for months of 1953
in 1954 the tour was the brainchild of
Prime Minister Winston Churchill who
recognized the appeal of Queen Elizabeth
to the masses and the possibilities
Sanchi favoured Queen presented for
building a positive image of England
abroad they're all a couple they went
around the world making Elizabeth the
first European monarch to do so she was
also the first reigning British monarch
to visit Australia New Zealand and Fiji
this trip was only the first of many
this Elizabeth would take as Queen
during her 65 years and counting as
Queen she has become the world's most
widely traveled monarch and by the way
as Queen she does have an easier time
than the rest of us because of the way
in British and international law works
which means that she doesn't actually
need to have a passport if she did have
a passport though there would be plenty
full she has made nearly 300 foreign
trips to 120 countries including Canada
in the United States New Zealand
Australia India Bermuda Iran Saudi
Arabia Qatar Thailand Brazil and Russia
these are but a few of the countries
she's visited some of the most notable
trips she's taken include the opening of
Canada's Parliament she's been the
honoree at a ticker tape parade in New
York City and she's awarded the mother
Teresa Order of Merit in India and she's
also spoken at the United Nations
traveling it's been a large part of
Queen Elizabeth's reign but representing
her nation abroad well that's not her
only duty as a monarch in a
constitutional monarchy she has tasked
with many domestic duties though she
does not get involved in politics she
must stay well informed of what is going
on within her country bands around the
world each day she receives piles of
reading material in case in red metal
boxes the tradition of these red boxes
dates back nearly two centuries and
until recently members of parliament
also received them Parliament's is
actually
the opposite to get digital versions of
these documents but the Queen remains
tied to paper delivery so those red
boxes continue to arrive daily bettered
or the material contains within
encompasses everything from foreign
intelligence to economic updates to the
most mundane matters of state reading
and digesting the information can take
several hours a day but it is a crucial
part of her role as leader even today at
the age of 90 she receives her red box
each day and takes the time to go
through the crucial information
contained within it Queen Elizabeth's
more public duties include presenting
medals issuing knighted xan's presiding
over many ceremonies that take place in
a society that still has a queen as she
has aged some of Elizabeth's duties have
been passed down to our children and to
our grandchildren particularly
ceremonies where the nobility received
their titles over the years Elizabeth's
family grew to include grandchildren and
great-grandchildren her family despite
their royal blood have not been immune
from the ups and downs of life and love
three of her four children have been
through divorces with the world watching
the death of Princess Diana shook the
entire family as well as the rest of the
world but it was in 1992 when much of
the royal family seemed to crumble with
the marriages of princess and Prince
Charles and Prince Andrew all coming to
their ends in one way or another it was
also that year that Windsor Castle
caught on fire and the public became
outraged at the idea that their tax
money would be used to rebuild it when
the Queen was one of the richest women
in the world that year though the Queen
demonstrated her political acumen when
it was announced that the royal family
would pay for the restoration of Windsor
Castle and in a reversal of a
thousand-year-old policy the family
would begin paying their taxes
[Music]
Queen Elizabeth she has long understood
the importance of public opinion she's
been the power behind the British
monarchies increased visibility in the
media she realized that the public
wanted to know more about the family
they wanted to feel like they knew the
Royals increased transparency it was one
way to help the royal family connect
with the public and it has long been a
hallmark of Elizabeth's reign hers was
the first televised coronation and then
she was the first to allow television
cameras into Buckingham Palace live
cameras were allowed into the palace
during President Nixon's visits and
informal events that included lunch and
the swapping of signed photographs
between the world leaders Elizabeth also
welcomed cameras into the family's lives
for the production of a documentary on
the Royals hoping to show them as simply
humans who loved their family members
but it wasn't until 2007 that Buckingham
Palace really go in The Times and
launched an official YouTube channel
this was 10 years after perhaps one of
the most important displays of
Elizabeth's use of the media to
effectively communicate with the public
her speech about Princess Diana
[Music]
when Princess Diana died amid the public
mourning and the private grief of the
family Elizabeth broke protocol
recognizing that the country and the
world needed to hear from the royal
family Princess Diana and the Queen they
were initially close in fact Diana even
called her mama but over time the
relationship became best strange diana
regularly broke royal protocol and add
the dirty laundry of her and Charles's
personal lives the Queen a stoic monarch
from they rather different generation
did not understand Diana's desire to be
involved with aids charities or her
willingness to talk publicly about the
disintegration of a marriage to this day
there are people like Diana's lover Dodi
Fayed Slava who blamed the Queen and the
royal family for the car crash that
killed Diana and his son when Queen
Elizabeth and her family did not
immediately express their grief publicly
the press and the people of the world
they were pretty outraged eventually
though Queen Elizabeth did give a
neither dress speaking about Diana and
the tragedy of her death the Queen she
spoke of Diana in the way most of the
world viewed her first I want to pay
tribute to Diana myself she was an
exceptional and gifted human being in
good times and bad she never lost her
capacity to smile and laugh nor to
inspire others with her warmth and
kindness I admired and respected her for
her energy and commitment to others and
especially for her devotion to her two
boys while public opinion didn't
immediately fully rebound in the Queen's
favor the address was helpful then
stemming the tide of criticism
unlike her children Queen Elizabeth
she had a long marriage she and Philip
have the longest marriage of anyone in
the royal family 2017 actually marks
their 70th wedding anniversary their
major wedding anniversaries they've long
been celebrated in England with their
twenty-fifth being marked by a party
that included other couples from around
England Zoo were also married on
November the 20th 1947 in 2007 the
couple sentimentally returned to their
honeymoon site in the Hampshire region
of England they'd like any common a
couple might do we created their
honeymoon photos at their 50th
anniversary Queen Elizabeth in what is
regarded as an emotional expression for
a member of the British monarchy sent
this of her husband and her marriage who
doesn't take easily two compliments but
he has quite simply it being my strength
and stay all these years and I and his
whole family and this and many other
countries oh him a debt pratik greater
than he would ever claim or we shall
ever know Queen Elizabeth's reign has
also been punctuated by celebrations of
milestones not just in her marriage but
also in the number of reigning years the
silver jubilee is celebrating 25 years
of her reign in 1977 was a nationwide
party marked by sporting events
carnivals concerts and general
festivities twenty-five years later in
2002 her golden jubilee was just as Mary
of an affair even though unfortunately
both her mother and sister had died
earlier in the year to mark this
occasion Queen Elizabeth and Prince
Philip travelled around the world
in June a Jubilee weekend was held to
mark the fifty years one event called
the party at the palace particularly
stood out Paul McCartney and Eric
Clapton performs and Brian May played a
version of God Save the Queen
it was a raucous celebration filled with
some of Britain's most recognizable
celebrities and it was watched all
around the world thousands of people
crowded London's parks and streets to
see their favorite performers sing along
with their favorite songs and most of
all to cheer for that
[Music]
though stoic and dutiful queen elizabeth
ii has set herself apart as a modern
monarch she is well known to be an
animal lover manta corgis are
recognizable parts of the royal family
perhaps almost as much as its human
members during her reign she has had
over 30 corgis as pets and they have
even been involved in public affairs
such as the opening ceremonies for the
london olympics the core use though they
haven't always been as cute and cuddly
as they look at one point the royal
family reportedly had to bring in an
animal psychologist to help improve the
dog's behavior when they started and
nipping at the many people who were
around the raw residences the Queen
herself was even injured once when she
found herself in the midst of ten
fighting corgis these incidents though
they did nothing to temper her love for
animals and the Queen's corgis will
forever be remembered as they are
included with Elizabeth's image on such
items as the golden jubilee
commemorative coins apart from owning
and pampering Corky's the Queen has also
shown herself to be an animal lover
through her support of charities among
the charities she supports are over four
dozen that support animals in need she
is also generous in her donations to
medical charities giving to nearly 100
of them she also donates money to her
church interestingly she takes this
money to the church in her purse making
sunday the only day of the week when she
carries money overall it is estimated
that the Queen's charitable efforts have
resulted in over 1 billion dollars being
donated to charity
Queen Elizabeth four seconds sheep has
been in the public eye since childhood
now in her 90s and her 65th year as
Queen she was a world leader for much of
the 20th century and has helped usher in
the 21st her reign has spans that of 12
US presidents 12 UK prime ministers 7
popes and six Archbishop's of Canterbury
she has replied to more than 3.5 million
pieces of Correspondence and received
thousands of birthday greetings
throughout her lifetime she has met with
leaders from all corners of the world
and surpassed longevity records of both
British and foreign monarchs she is one
of only five British monarchs who have
ruled for more than 50 years and in 2015
she became the longest reigning British
monarch previously that title had been
held by Queen Victoria Elizabeth's
great-great-grandmother who reigned for
63 years Queen Elizabeth the second
she's an icon of the 20th and 21st
centuries a strong female leader who
retains a love of her people and a
strong standing in the international
community
she helped bring the monarchy into the
modern world and remain stoic and
dutiful through even the most trying of
times god save the queen so I really
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe but
without brand new videos twice a week
and as always thank you for watching